mastering a foreign language is
actually within everyone's reach but
if on the one hand mastering
syntactic and lexical and grammatical structures
in juggling verb tenses modes
etc etc is actually
something that everyone can achieve
on the other hand few people actually
manage to speak a foreign language
with  a native or almost native accent
hello everyone I'm luca di luca
lampariello dot com today I'm going to tell you
how to be able to speak a
foreign language with a native accent a hundred
native speakers is not as difficult as
you think and how to do it in another
video made on  youtube
I explained how I managed to go
from an atrocious accent in English he has an
almost reason accent in a short amount
of time what happened is that
the moment he crosses the in which I went
from a one hundred atrocious he has a
native accent and in the moment  in which I
began to speak almost like an
American my schoolmates or
my a  my friends actually made fun
of me American English is
much more nasal than Italian that's
what happened and that for my
classmates hearing me speak in a different
way
was kind of special and that was the
moment that made the difference  between
speaking like an Italian as
an Italian would speak by now and speaking almost like
an American because basically I
resisted the social pressure of
my companions of my friends who are
part of the Italian and Italian tribe and I
wanted to take on another
identity beyond the  my famed
linguist steven kosher among many
good things done wrote an article about
acquiring an accent in a
foreign language
in his article he states something that is
seemingly shocking but
ultimately makes sense stephen makes the
seemingly
provocative statement that everyone
even adults succeed and
very quickly acquire a foreign accent is
just choose  not to speak with
that accent because they feel a bit
stupid and this has exactly to do
with what I was saying just now is
that it is not just a
question of language, i.e. the difficulty
of articulating sounds or not hearing them,
it is  of a mere
psychological question and that is what made
the difference in my case is to
want to attribute the foreign accent
also to another identity and therefore to
belong to the American tribe
besides my own
the will to belong to another
tribe  or to embrace another tribe in
addition to one's own a is a
particularly relevant psychological factor but it
is also important in all of this to
consider the people with whom we
develop an accent in my case for
example the acquisition of an
almost native accent coincided exactly
with  the work that I started with
my teacher susan of whom I always talk
and whom I thank again by spending time
with her in fact they were just water  I see
his way of speaking his accent and
his intonation but above all his
way of being his way of
behaving relating to me and to others
they often say that we are the result
of the five people with whom we spend
most of the time
now I don't know if it's five if it's six it
's seven but the most important thing is
not only the quantity but the quality of the
people around you and so it's
crucial when you develop an accent
you want to developed an accent in a
specific mother tongue to spend time
with people who  respect and build your
identity around those people
again in his short but intense
academic paper steven klein explains how
language and accent have two
fundamental functions the first function is
obviously to communicate with
other human beings but the second
function is here  speaks more
specifically between 100 and that the accent
is a sort of social marker if you
think about it as an Italian one of the  the first
things you notice when an
unknown person talks to you is this where
he comes from he comes from calabria and he speaks like this he
comes from good where he speaks so well from
florence he speaks like this if on the one
hand the accent already defines the
geographical region where you were born
from  The other also somehow defines
your social class what I
'm trying to say is that the accent
defines again a specific
identity and if you want to acquire a
native accent you have to identify yourself with
the other person it's not just about
imitating that  person but it's about
being someone other than yourself and
this is a fundamental point that
also defines what you will do to assume
to acquire a foreign accent
one thing I used to do often and now
I do a little less is to
watch movies take
specific movie clips and mimic ad
nauseum what the actors say
the way they say it and it's not
just about saying things exactly
what they say but to take into
consideration all the surrounding things
because they revolve around these words
such as the face the gestures the behaviors
etc etc
and this is very important and it gave me
the possibility to develop an
almost native accent in other foreign languages ​​in
addition to  'american english
here we are at the end of the video i hope
you enjoyed the video and yes it
was helpful but i wanted to give a quick
final summary to acquire a
native accent in a foreign language it
is important to be ready to
embrace another cultural identity
but this  it doesn't mean abandoning
one's second it is important to spend
time with other people because it's not
just the sounds but the experiences the smiles
the looks the understanding the gestures that
render and create and shape a
linguistic and third identity instead of imitating
like a parrot take into
consideration  everything that has to
do with human communication and
therefore still u  na time from words
to face gestures from sounds and try
to imitate actors to imitate
people and it must basically be
like a game
if you enjoyed the video and want to
know more steet a huge article
on this fascinating topic on my
site  www.lucazaia.it how to
see the site well just click on the
link in the description box you can
read the article you can listen to
it as well as all the other articles and
you can leave comments so I'll
wait for you there thanks again for
listening and see you in  a bit on
youtube
[Music]